كريم يونس اصبح حرا بعد 40 عاما من
الانتظار داخل سجون اسرائيل اول مكان توجه
اليه كان قبر والدته التي حرمه الاحتلال
من وداعها قبل سبعه اشهر وكانت تلقب بام
الاسرى
التي خبرها منذ سنين طويله
من الرئاسه والمسؤولين الفلسطينيين وقاده
الحركه الاسيره
[تصفيق]
وهو يحمل رسائل من الاسرى للفلسطينيين
كافه
الادراك الاسرى بانه لا يمكن ان تكون لنا
قائمه دون الوحده الوطنيه وان لوحده قانون
الانتصار والفرقه والتشدد هي قانون
الاندثار وقانون
الرجوع الى الخلف
[موسيقى]
لم تمتثل العائله والمهنئون لتهديدات
اليمين الاسرائيلي بمنع اي مظاهر احتفاليه
لتصل التهديدات الى المطالبه بسحب الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه وحق المواطنه بهدف حرماني
كريم وابن عمه ماهر الذي سيخرج من السجن
بعد اشهر من العيش في قريتهما عاره داخل
الخط الاخضر
ويعتبر كريم يونس احد اقدم الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في السجون الاسرائيليه وجهت
له تهم تتعلق بعضويته في حركه فتح التي
كانت محظوره انذاك وقتل جندي اسرائيلي حكم
عليه بالاعدام شنقا ثم خفف الى السجن
اربعين عاما دخل السجن عام
1983 وهو في الثانيه والعشرين من عمره
وخرج اليوم بعمر 62 عاما لم يشمل بصفقات
تبادل الاسرى ورفضت اسرائيل الافراج عنهم
مرارا بحجه انه يحمل الجنسيه الاسرائيليه
هو واحد من 25 فلسطينيه تواصل اسرائيل
اعتقالهم منذ ما قبل توقيع اتفاقيه اوسلوه
عام 93 من القرن الماضي
ترك خلفه اكثر من اربعه الاف اسيرا
يستعدون حسب وصفهم لخوض معارك كبيره في ظل
التهديدات التي يتلقونها من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اليمنيه عدم التعامل مع قضيه
الاسراف قضيه سياسيه من الدرجه الاولى
يضعف الحركه الاسيره مما يؤدي الى ان
يعاني الاسرى من الاهمال الطبي من القمع
والتنكيل المستمر من قبل سلطه السجون هناك
سياسات يعني كامله تطبق على الاسرى
المفروض ان يتم مواجهتها كما يجب هنا
تتجسد في صور معاناه الاسير المحرر كريم
يونس ذكريات واربعين عاما تتحدث عنه وعن
الاسره خلف قطباني سجون الاحتلال واملهم
كما يقولون اكمال الطريق للتحرر من الاسرع
وتحرير وطنهم الذي دفعوا من اجله سنوات
شبابها المدير الجزيره من بلده عارف
المثلث داخل الخط الاخضر